hello welcome we are so glad to have
several of you a few hundred already
here today and really appreciate your
time
my name is dave herron i work on our
team that supports teachers in school
districts at khan academy
and i am joined today about two miles
away from her home in san francisco by
my colleague vicky lang who is a
learning scientist on our team so hello
vicky
and i'm also joined by my colleague dan
who helps lead our marketing team from
san mateo california hi dan and he will
help actually be um
surfacing some of your questions all
throughout the webinar and we'll leave
the last few minutes of the webinar to
answer as many as we can
and so you'll see a question tab on the
go to webinar panel and if this is your
first webinar with us then go ahead and
take a look at that and at any moment
when a question pops into your head
please put that in there so that we can
do our best to answer as many as
possible
so we're here to spend the next 30
minutes or so on the topic you should be
seeing on your screen
some of you may have found yourself over
the last four five six weeks maybe
suddenly as homeschool teachers in
addition to all the other
responsibilities you're balancing
and we know it is a whole lot to juggle
um here at khan academy we have created
daily schedules and now weekly math
learning plans to try to support you as
you support your kids
so that they can stay on track as much
as possible in their math courses as
well as other courses that they may be
missing in school
and so we're here to break down these
plans for you
and i want to thank before we move on
some of the key supporters who have been
providing support to khan academy so
that we can increase
the amount of support we're providing
throughout this time and you'll see
those names there on the screen
our main goal is to break down the plans
for you explain all the ins and outs of
these weekly math learning plans and
again answer as many of your questions
as possible
and before we move on
i'm going to start a poll to see how
familiar this audience is with the
learning plans that we're talking about
so take the next few seconds
once it pops up on your screen
to tell us
what best represents your familiarity
are you i've never seen them before i'm
here to learn or i've seen them but i
have not used them with my kids
or finally i have started using them
already with my kids
so we'll take about 10 more seconds
you haven't yet fill in your vote
three
two
one about two-thirds of you have
submitted your vote and here's where
we're at
over half of you have never seen these
learning plans before so thank you for
joining despite not having that past
familiarity we'll walk you through how
to find them
and then the others about a quarter have
seen them but i haven't started using
them and we do have some maybe
um intermediate or advanced users who
have already started using them with
your kids
we'll be really
appreciative of any feedback or
questions that you have since you've
already started using them and we have a
survey at the end of the webinar if you
want to give us more advice on how we
can improve them moving forward
so given that over half of you have
never seen them before let's start with
a pretty basic question i'll take this
one vicki how do i even find the
learning plans to begin with
so if you go to our website at
khanacademy.org
on the very home page which you should
see an example of on the screen now
there will be a blue banner at the top
that links you to some of our remote
learning resources
and if you click that link you'll be
brought to that page that's shown on the
right side of the screen
where one of the main options are the
weekly learning plans
so that will give you access to all of
the learning plans that we've created so
far
we have them at many different grade
levels for math and we recently
published a high school biology learning
plan as well
they're all in a format that's very easy
to print if you do have a printer
accessible for you you know the learning
plans for kids are often helpful to have
in print form and so when you open it
you may notice the formatting looks
different than a regular word document
but that makes it easy if you press
control p or whatever the shortcut is on
your computer to print those out
so you might be multitasking right now
and and following those steps to access
the learning plans and just as two other
quick reminders i should have mentioned
this right at the beginning but there's
a copy of these slides
available to download as a pdf within
the browser that you have available
and then second we're recording the
webinar and we'll send you a copy of the
recording soon after within a few hours
after the conclusion
let's move on though who are the plans
for what's the big goal or idea behind
these plans vicki
well um as you said they're for students
from third grade through high school for
mathematics and then we also have one
for high school biology and they're
really for
um providing a clear goal for what to
work on week to week we know that it's
great to set a large goal of being ready
for next year when school starts again
and it can also be really helpful in
reaching our goal to break it down into
smaller steps so we're breaking that
goal down into week by week by week
steps to get you ready for your child
ready for next year
um and on the next slide we can see
um that
the real audience for this is folks
whose districts maybe have not provided
enough support or you're looking for
something a little bit beyond what your
district has provided for you this is an
overwhelming time for school districts
what they've been able to provide has
really varied and we want to make sure
that everybody has access to a plan that
they can use to um to make sure that
your kiddos are ready for school next
year
perfect and as you mentioned these are
far more specific than the daily
schedules that we've put out right if i
know we're receiving this question
already in the chat room that i think of
the daily schedule saying maybe at this
time per day you could work on this
course if you're in sixth grade the
weekly learning plan is gonna get way
more specific on what unit and what the
actual goal could be to complete by the
end of it so let's talk about that
what would you need to know about the
learning plans to just even get started
on that first day with the with um your
kids
well so if we if we look at a sample we
can look at that sixth grade sample
learning plan
um
and i'll just show you how it's
structured there
um so at the beginning there's gonna be
some instructions about how to use it as
well as you can see it says click here
for explainer video that's a short video
where sal talks more about what to do
with it and then there's some
instructions here about how you're going
to get your kids started so let's for
example talk about a kiddo who's was
supposed to be finishing sixth grade
right now will be entering seventh grade
next year they've already learned
probably a lot of the sixth grade
content so we're gonna this is gonna
explain to have them start with the
course challenge
to earn credit for the things that they
already know and dave will talk more
about that in a few minutes about how
that mastery system works and the course
challenge works but they're going to get
credit for what they already know by
taking sort of a pre-test
and then they're going to in the system
have a sort of a to-do list of work that
they haven't mastered yet and that's
going to map onto this table here so
what you're seeing in this table is the
20-week version of finishing sixth grade
um and the 20 weeks will take you right
up to august to when seventh grade would
be begin um and in this table you'll see
that each row is a week
with an end date on friday and then the
color changes represent a different unit
of instruction that's starting so for
example in this one in the first week
that student would take that course
challenge to pre-test out of some of the
content then they would begin the ratios
rates and percentages unit and they
would be aiming to get about 600 points
that week in that unit the next week
they would continue work on that unit
it's a pretty big unit they would aim to
get to
1200 points that's another 600 points
for a total of 1200. the following week
they would aim to get to 1900 and then
they would move on to the next course
or to the next unit i mean
um
you are going to
want to decide between um the 20 week
and the 12 week options if you would
keep scrolling down here you would see
that there's a 12 week option that has
you finished by the end of june and that
just depends on how much time you want
to invest you're going to be able to fit
in a little bit more content if you go
with the 20 week option but we wanted to
make sure that if you want to spend only
a shorter amount of time and get to
maybe the time when the school year
would typically have ended that you're
able to hit all the really high points
so that's what the 12-week one does
and then if you keep scrolling you'll
notice there's another pair of tables
and these are for a foundational
learning plan so those first two tables
tell a sixth grader how to finish sixth
grade
this second pair of tables give you a
plan for our arithmetic class which is a
foundational skills class that supports
sixth grade so if you have even more
time that you want to invest in sixth
grade or if your student is struggling a
little bit with sixth grade you might
have them also work on this arithmetic
course to build some of those
foundational skills to support it
um and that's that's kind of what you
need to know there
and then if we look um
here we can see that the most important
time in getting these learning plans off
the ground or really in getting anything
off the ground with a kid is the first
two weeks the beginning of it where you
want to really establish your routine
and get into a pattern with it and you
can things that can help you with that
or making the plan physical if you do
have a printer printed if you don't have
a printer sketch it on a piece of paper
make it a place where they can write and
interact with and really see on the
refrigerator or somewhere
and making it a clear habit where
there's a routine to it first i'm going
to check my
um check my goal then i'm going to open
and do some work then i'm going to
record my progress every day the same
time every day
maybe
um and with that let's see if dave can
tell us a little bit more about the
mastery system because those tables
really are grounded in getting to about
70 mastery on each of those units so we
need to understand what those points are
and how you would get mastery and how
that would work
absolutely so as vicky just showed there
are references to different point goals
for learners all throughout these
learning plans and we know that it is
motivating to have a clear goal but it's
also i'm sure helpful for you as the
parent or adult to just be able to know
how those points are maybe calculated
and how to encourage
um your kids
to achieve those goals
so let me show you a few screens this on
the screen right now is our third grade
plan this would be third grade common
core
and on the left hand column are all the
different units in our third grade math
course
and on the right hand side are all of
the points available for each unit
every unit has a certain number of
skills and every skill is 100 points and
so in the unit at the top maybe it's
worth 800 points it's got eight
different skills in it
those points are really important for
understanding the learning plans because
all of the goals reference unit mastery
points
the other thing i want to mention is
vicki alluded to the course challenge
so if we were talking maybe in september
or near the start of a school year then
a course challenge
may not be the first step for a student
if they're just getting started on third
grade but considering that it's
springtime and that your kids have
already learned a lot of math this year
the course challenge could be a great
way for them to
quickly place out of some of the skills
that they're already confident in
so i would guide your kid to click on
the course challenge that's the first
step and it will scroll them down to the
very end actually and they'll get
started on that mixed review of all
different skills from throughout the
year just remember to remind them that
it's totally okay if you don't know
these answers because it will include
some from the later units that they may
not have learned yet
i also want to show a brief video that
goes over some of the other learning
experiences for students so that i can
explain a bit about what you might be
seeing in the next few days
so here i'm as a learner clicking on
that blue button in just a minute to
start in on a lesson
here we're in addition and subtraction
within 100
and there's going to be a bunch of
learning resources our videos and
articles and then there's gonna be
practice resources so i'm clicking on
that first practice problem set
the practice problems some of them are
gonna be only four problems some seven
the longest might be fourteen if it's
like a lot of procedural fluency and if
i'm stuck on the problem what i just did
is i clicked on a video it was
it was listed right there because it's
really closely aligned to the practice
that i'm doing
so if i'm done watching the video and
now i know how to do this problem of 92
plus 3 then i can answer it 95
if i'm still not sure i could get a hint
and the hint is going to mark the
problem wrong because it gives away the
answer
but encourage your kids to take hints
when we look at our research the kids
that take more hints even though they're
getting the initial problem wrong they
end up making faster progress overall
so i'm getting the questions right and
getting instant feedback on this you
might see the little dots at the bottom
of the screen turning green
so i've got a few more to go
and if i do get
to
70
or higher then i'm going to get points
in this case i'll get half the points
for that scale 50. so that's
contributing to that goal in the
learning plan
and i'm just about to finish with the
last problem and because i'm about to
ace i think this problem set and get 100
i'm going to get almost all the points
for the scale so there should be some
confetti that rains down from the
ceiling i just received 80 points
not quite 100 because it was just one
practice set and i haven't shown that i
still understand it when it's mixed in
with a whole bunch of different concepts
but i'm on my way towards my goal for
that week
so if i go back to the unit overall then
i'll see here in the top left corner i
have now a total of 240 points
so i know that was brief but that's a
that's kind of the three-minute version
of our mastery system
i think it's closely related to a
question we've already been hearing a
lot how do i know if my kids are on
track
so we do have parent accounts that you
can create on khan academy when we
designed those parent accounts it was in
a pre-covered world where we did not
expect parents to be
home schooling in mass and so the amount
of detail you'll find on there will be
helpful for getting an overview of how
much time your kids are spending and
what they've worked on recently but it's
not going to give the detailed points
that you might need to tell if they're
on track for the learning plan
so instead what we'd recommend is just
having your kid maybe once every few
days maybe once a week
whatever might work for you
showing you their screen and talking
about how it's going and then you can
look at the points together and turn it
into a conversation of sorts
here again on the right hand i'll see
the point values for each unit
and that if i'm just to sort of do a
crosswalk for the learning plan
then on the screen you'll see intro to
multiplication i currently have 660
points so i've written that in there in
pink into the second week of the
learning plan i'm so close
but good news in one digit
multiplication i have 1050 points so
i've exceeded my goal
the last one that i wanna talk over is
how you might help your kids when you
are stuck
i taught ninth grade algebra one for
most of my teaching career and even
though i was a math teacher if i were
asked by someone more the fourth grade
level on how to break down a skill it
would be tough because it's hard to know
how to teach something at that level
given what they understand currently so
don't feel the pressure that you have to
be the teacher
instead if they come to you and they're
stuck and they're saying one topic's
really confusing
one strategy we recommend is just to
watch one of our videos with them
to see how you might go about explaining
it chances are after that video you will
understand it quite a bit better than
your own kid
and that might help you then
coach them a bit on the next few
problems
if they seem just stuck on one specific
problem
again we recommend they take a look at
the hints they'll have multiple hints
available for each problem so they can
get just the first bit of the solution
and maybe then they'll have enough of
what they need to finish out the problem
or they can click all the way through to
the answer
but there is another scenario where you
might anticipate just high levels of
frustration maybe your kid gets a lot of
math anxiety
or maybe they just have are already
proving to have a tough time as they try
to transition to this really difficult
learning environment
of um learning from home so if you think
that they are going to have some of that
general frustration
you'll see on the screen a list of our
different courses
you might decide that you're going to
start a level earlier build their
confidence
and as as vicki mentioned these plans
are designed for third grade to algebra
two
if your kids are more at a kindergarten
first second grade
enrollment or math level
you might consider also checking out
some of the math resources from khan
academy kids
back to you vicki
i'm meeting um and
so how do we keep our kids motivated to
follow through with these plans week to
week well
um
motivation for kids is for anybody
really is about value like what value
are you finding in the activity that
you're doing we're not motivated to do
things that we don't think are valuable
um it also can be about agency we're not
we're sometimes not motivated to do
things that we feel like we don't have a
choice about so the key here really is
to think about what are your kids value
what's going to make it interesting and
exciting for them and what's going to
make them feel like they have some
choice and some ownership over the work
that they're doing
on this side there's a couple of
suggestions here
you can take on a challenge in parallel
with them so that the value comes in
spending time together with a parent who
also is modeling learning you can use a
simple reward system you can give them
some choices about maybe where when in
the day they work on it um but for a
full webinar on motivation for your
kiddos during this crisis time we're
going to have a full webinar on that
next wednesday april 29th
we also are going to have a webinar on
motivating and managing multiple kiddos
on different schedules on may 4th
and we had a webinar
a few weeks ago on structuring it was
called structuring the day for kids two
through seven because we did it with con
kids but what's really communicated
there is structure and choice and
connection and keeping your kids
motivated and kind of bought into
learning by how you might
schedule some choice into their day
and so there's some other resources
there for you but next wednesday
motivation
um and then i think a big question here
with these learning plans for me if i
was a parent i am a parent right now but
if i was using this um
at home
would be
you know that the first week has already
passed in the learning plans or maybe
this doesn't work for my kiddo in some
other way in the way that it's
structured how can i adapt it to meet
the needs of my own child
you might need to do a different number
of weeks for example you might need to
start from an earlier grade in order to
build confidence if you anticipate that
your kiddo is going to struggle
you might want to revise the goal each
week especially if your child earns a
lot of points on that course challenge
up front the specific numbers that are
week by week and those goals might not
make sense or your child might find that
they get to a week where they've already
earned most of the points in that unit
from the course challenge and so maybe
they can work a little bit ahead to the
next week we really want you to take
what's here as just inspiration to be
able to design a plan that's going to
work for your specific child in your
specific situation
given that the first couple weeks have
already passed that are in the learning
plan you might do something like use the
12-week plan but start it now instead of
starting it three weeks ago
and it'll take you maybe into july
but really we want you to
just figure out a way to
use this idea
to build a plan with small goals for
your child that will work for you
and with that i think we're going to
take some questions
i'm already seeing lots of great
questions in the doc
and i'll turn it over to dan
hi everyone dave i wasn't sure if you
were going to have a poll before we jump
into the question
oh the poll actually we're going to put
as part of the survey right after the
webinar um on actually your advice on
how we might name these learning plans
if learning plan isn't the best name
we'll get your thoughts on that after
perfect well thanks dave and vicky hi
everyone i'm dan and i'll be moderating
the live qa portion of this session
two things to do before we move into the
question portion um as dave mentioned
earlier
please download this for the
presentation they're in the handout
section and a recording of this as well
as the handout will be emailed to those
who registered and we'll post a
recording after this as well and the
recording and the document covers
everything from the learning plans what
they're for some of the recommendations
as well as links to other resources that
we have available
and then the second thing that we want
to ask of you all is if you have any
questions please add them now i know
there's already a lot of really good
questions in the question box and i'll
facilitate and vicky and and dave will
do the hard work of actually answering
the questions
so we already have a couple and vicki
this one's probably most appropriate for
you
jignesh asks based on what sal states
today on axia so sal was on axios um
what
understanding that kids going through
potentially going through a five to six
months learning loss and forgetting
another six months worth of potential
learning kids may end up being behind a
complete year
what are the practical steps we can do
to bridge the gap and actually that's
why we created these learning plans in
the first place so vicky yeah
yeah this this just my heart hurts so
much when i think about uh when i think
about this um and i know districts are
working really hard to figure out what
they're going to do in the fall to make
sure that kids aren't falling behind um
what you can do as the grown-up in the
meantime is to keep your kid practicing
um in just gentle ways just keep
don't push math all the time in a way
that makes them go no i don't want to
but just gently reminding them that that
math is part of the their life helping
them do a little bit of math every day
with my my daughter's six and we have a
lot of mathematical conversations while
i'm make doing something in the kitchen
or while we're picking up our toys we
count the toys we'll talk about math um
as we're walking to the park well maybe
estimate does that bush have do you
think that's more than 10 flowers or
less than 10 flowers and just trying to
bring in casual ways of talking about
math throughout the day in natural ways
with your child and then if you can help
them if they are um willing to engage
with some online math learning like what
we're providing at khan academy i think
that's really really beneficial to
really keep them moving forward with
those on grade level skills
um yeah but continually just bringing
math in
perfect and dave we have a lot of
questions around standards alignment so
from cheryl
she's asking thank you for doing this
are the lessons geared towards states
with high math achievements such as
massachusetts or others such as
california and genie asked a similar
question are these based on particular
state standards
yeah great question so the third through
eighth grade and then the high school
curations those are going to be common
core curations
and we um
the rigor of the questions
um
should be aligned with many of the
state's summative exams but you know be
the judge of that as you take a look
yourself and definitely consider
combining the resources we have with
other things that the district may be
providing other resources
um especially some of the open-ended
responses that they might be getting
good practice resources on from their
district
perfect vicki we're getting a lot of
questions on around like how much time
a student will will need for each of
these um units so from cindy asks how
much time approximately per day or per
week are the schedules based on and lisa
asks for high school algebra one
roughly how much time should a
student dedicate to this to complete
everything in the 20 weeks
that's a great question we designed them
with the assumption that your student
might spend a similar amount of time to
what they would spend in school so about
45 minutes to an hour
a day five days a week um for that
amount of time and the amount of time
that it's going to really require them
to work through all the work is going to
depend a lot on how much they already
remember and test out of in the course
challenge
some students may move much much more
quickly some students may take a little
more time um it also may vary week to
week depending on how much they remember
in that particular unit but that's the
basic
recommendation
and kind of to piggyback off of that um
stephanie asks like how do we know
whether to use the 12-week or the
20-week versions
i mean that's really just up to you and
how much time you want to invest and
whether you
want your child to continue to practice
math all the way up until school starts
again in the fall or only through when
the regular school year might have ended
um it you also might be deciding between
the regular on grade level learning plan
and the foundational learning plan um
and our thought is you might do both at
the same time
you might also choose the foundational
one if your child is struggling a little
bit more in math
or
for specific targeted topics you might
dip into that to support some learning
that they're doing in the regular grade
level
and stephanie's also asking can she
switch from one to the other and i think
the answer to that is absolutely test it
out and see what's what's most
comfortable and appropriate for you
yeah
dave uh elaine asks my my seventh grader
uses khan academy for math all the time
how is this how is this different
well the content should be similar the
student experience on what getting
mastery points looks similar as well but
two things might feel different for them
one would be having a really clear goal
and second might be the extra
involvement from you
and those i think can make a really big
difference with the way they engage with
math but again the actual content and
the mastery learning plans for a system
is the same as in regular school year
and a little bit related to that dave
angelo's asking if my child's already
doing khan academy with his class
would you still recommend him doing the
learning plan
i would recommend having a conversation
with them and just seeing how they're
feeling about clarity and what they
should be working on if the answer comes
back a little tepid of like well we're
not really receiving much to work on
because it is pretty difficult for many
districts to just get enough learning
resources out there in short amount of
time then this could supplement that but
if they seem to already have a full
plate of math practice coming from their
teacher and district then that might be
a signal that these learning plans
aren't necessary at this time
perfect
and vicky we have a question we talked
about
grade level and foundational things but
there's a question um where would you
start your child's working well above
grade level
yeah i would start with the course
challenge for the next grade level or
the course challenge for this grade
level that's a really good way to for
your child to very quickly in just about
30 or 45 minutes get credit for the
things they already know
um and make sure that they're not they
don't create any gaps and things that
they don't know um but that's a great
way to kind of accelerate progress
um dave and then we're getting quite a
few questions on like how do i track my
kids progress how should i think about
it so angela degati asks do you
you might get well
um how is your child how do you see if
your child's doing uh in these skills
yeah so we sort of touched on this
within the webinar that the data
available in the parent dashboards is
probably not going to be as detailed as
you're looking for since it was not
created with the homeschool mentality in
mind that being said you have two
options first option is you could
actually create a teacher account and
enroll your kid as your own student and
then you will get detailed data and
there's a lot of resources on our site
for the teacher
data reports
or you could just have them show you
their screen and have a conversation
about it and that's kind of our primary
recommendation because it doesn't
require you to know all the ins and outs
of our teacher reports
perfect and i think we have time for one
more question and viki this one will be
for you what's the difference between
the super ultra strong foundation plan
versus the super fun plan um and then
related to that is is the 20 week just
more content or is it the same but just
spread out over a different number of
weeks
yeah um so the difference between the
the first
um i can't remember how we structured
them but there's a or what we call them
with the super fun or super great um but
the first learning plan that has the
grade level third grade course the sixth
grade course is just the grade level
content that your student would have
gotten at school this year it's the
content from the entire grade not
starting now but the entire grade um in
that that grade level course the
foundational one the one that says
foundational in the name of it um is a
related course like early math or
arithmetic that has more basic skills
that probably have that grade level
skill but also stretch back a couple
grades to bring in some core skills to
really build a strong foundation of
earlier mathematics and math
fundamentals so that's the difference
there
i would say
try i would say try to do both or lean
into the grade level one um unless your
child's struggling and then lean into
the foundational one and the difference
between 20 and 12 weeks it's they're
both the whole course in the 12 week we
pulled out some of the units that are a
little bit um less critical they're
still all math is important but maybe
the less critical for that grade level
and put them as optional at the end and
so the the 12 weeks just really breaks
up the most important key skills from
that grade and then it says if you have
extra time here's the other units that
you're going to want to work on and
whereas the 20 week just embeds the
whole thing in the order you would
normally do it
perfect so i think we're at time so
thank you dave and and thank you vicky
for sharing your expertise and we wanted
to thank all of you our audience for
taking the time out of your busy
afternoons to be with us we know you're
extremely busy and we appreciate you
investing your time in this session um
if you missed something or you want to
go back and play replay something we
know this is a lot to cover in a short
period of time this recording uh it will
post it tomorrow it'll be made available
for those who registered or
automatically be sent to you in an email
along with uh the presentation um and we
do have a quite a few other resources
available at khan academy.org so if you
go there there's going to be a blue
ribbon at the top speaking specifically
to remote learning um so you can always
check that out we're we're making
updates quite frequently every day in
fact
so you can always go to khan academy.org
and then before we sign off we want to
ask you to do us one more favor and
please take the poll that pops up at the
very end of this webinar and let us know
two things first how could you make how
we could make future iterations of this
session even better for you all and then
what kind of sessions would you like to
see next we've been asking this at the
end of each webinar and it's helping us
kind of plan what's most useful for you
all so um please be sure to do that and
then dave mentioned the poll in terms of
like
how to actually name these in a way that
resonates with you all so please please
fill that out for us
and in closing uh we know you're
juggling a lot as parents right now um
this is kind of uncharted territory
you're asking to be a parent as well as
a teacher and we we want to be here to
support you and it and one more thing is
just we want here we here at khan
academy want to remind you to be kind to
yourselves you know these schedules may
appear to be a lot um they're really
recommendations and um you know use them
in the way that you feel like it's most
appropriate and don't feel pressure to
you know complete all 20 weeks or why
not try to get through as much as you
can um in a way that feels right for you
so from all of us at khan academy thanks
again and thanks for joining us and
goodbye